welcome to this video playing bet fort
from Denmark to see going either trying
a Danish gambit but I'm declining it's
just them just much easier to play then
then they accept it accepted version
should be to really interesting yeah at
some point he will will take on deform I
know it still taking like that wow
really hmm take you to Queen takes this
is a bit a bit uncomfortable you can
take I can certainly take here wish
Brooke f1 I have a hard time to believe
that this is anything anything serious
am I take here should G 4 I can I can
also play Knight f6 this intermediate
move
Queen Queen takes Bishop b2 looks
totally totally weird can also play
night c 2 and then then take G form but
night why not Knight f6 just attacking
the the bishop again and if he takes I
take g4 and i'm just a pawn up with a
clearly better position he's got his
King position wrecked yeah just Queen g4
I guess
yeah just just that point I can give
this check I wonder if I should maybe
play a queen king to d7 and not um yeah
obvi should be seven actually why not
Bishop is so i can do that as well just
castling next we cannot take because of
rupee aid yeah sure now is grabbing
pawns um 95 or it could also start with
with rook d8 property 892 start like
that how to get that tech going 95 maybe
95 queen g3 I can take III then that's
very strong actually we cannot take with
the poem because of Bishop H form and
queen takes Bishop dialysis this is the
Queen Queen takes Bishop g5 wasn't
wasn't much better white resigns yeah
this this whole opening is not simply
not working I mean maybe he can make and
of course player C takes d4 I now
transposed to the main lining of the
decline gambit but but this is just
losing took him in 11 seconds to get
them and then black wins I Queenie force
even stronger winds the rook in the
corner but ok this is also just a flat
win no way for him to save it it's a
pawn down it has a bad position check
grabbing this is yeah well yeah here if
you lose lost the queen but this is not
not much better really
and you're collapsing on d 2 yeah this
opening is just not playable in that way
what he what he must do is some hmm you
should just play play this to transpose
to them to the main line here check and
this has been known for a number of
years to BM to be okay for black but
it's also noting that wider particularly
should fear it's just about equal I'm
sorry yeah this is the best that right
can get in this opening any fancy
deviations are mostly worse for him like
we saw in the game alright thanks for
watching